uh we do not follow anyone we just saw
what we
uh what the police did to the student on
tv
and so that's why we are angry and we
wish to come out to support i usually
come during the morning because there is
much less people doing the morning
because there's people staying overnight
will leave and no no people will come
through in the morning so i would just
come here to sew a shop called this is a
sharp place and everyone can use it uh
you can see
we have waters
shampoo inside everyone is free to use
it uh it is mainly for people staying
overnight because they cannot get home
so they would use this place to take a
quick shower because we now do not have
the cleaners to come so we have to clean
the toilet by ourselves we have so
many stuff here
all donated by the public this area
there are a lot of tables and chairs for
students for people to sit here and
study
and do some refreshing because we are
students we have to take care of
somebody doing this movement because we
are now longer term so we just come here
and study all of us want to achieve the
great democracy from the government and
we hope that by staying here all over
the time the government will give up
someday and to listen our voice so
that's why we stay here to my father and
mother i try to avoid these issues they
are not very supportive because they
always say
we can do nothing to the government they
do not stop me from coming here but they
also warn me is there anything happening
please come back as soon as possible my
bottom line is when the right police
come against me i would just go i'm not
afraid of the clearance of the scene
because after that we'll just come out
again so until we get the real democracy
it's all about faith when they come to
this place we go to another place so it
doesn't matter